dear champion bending company this
letter is in regards to vending machine
seven one four located in st. Andrews
Hospital which should have given me
peanut M&Ms regrettably it didn't the
machine over there I candy stuck happens
sometimes
I found this upsetting as I was very
hungry and also my wife had died ten
minutes earlier she's gone maybe I
should start from the beginning I get up
every morning at 5:30 I never thought
I'd be one of those people who carried a
briefcase money it always reminds me of
carrying a lunchbox to school Davis we
handle quite a bit of money I don't want
to say how much cuz I think that would
be inappropriate okay it's six billion I
don't think they liked me that much at
first I wasn't all that ambitious also
he told me once I don't like you Davis
Julia was a nice girl a good person
other than that I don't think I knew who
she really was she always said I didn't
pay attention
I find I'm suddenly starting to notice
things I never saw before well maybe I
saw them I just wasn't paying attention
yeah
bill said it himself if you want to fix
something you have to take everything
apart and figure out what's important
and miss her
I'm trying to
what are we doing again
to take apart my marriage
there was love to me joy I just didn't
take care
the bulldozer it can buy almost anything
any bit
I'll better stash down spent in a higher
shot from kami adalah bay nas not like
me so for Satish mr. hot stuff